>> Alright, so Michael. Last set of features that that's come up
with three or four, three or four more features and then move on.
>> Sure.
>> So come up with a couple.
>> Alright, so I could, sometimes I'll look at the menu that's
posted outside, and I'll see if the, you know? How pricey it is.
>> Okay, so cost. Right, so cost can be represented as discrete
input. By the way, it could also be represented as an actual number.
Right? We could say, look it's cheap, it's moderately
expensive, it's really expensive or you could have a number
which is the average cost of an entry. And it
doesn't really matter for, for what we're talking about now
but just some way of representing cost. Okay. Just
give me one or two more features but I want
to give me some features that don't have anything to
do with the restraunt itself but might still be important.
>> Hmm.
>> because, by the way, hot date probably doesn't have anything to
do with the restaurant itself. So, even though we've
been talking the features of the restaurant. We've actually
been picking up, at least, one feature that doesn't
have anything to do directly with the restaurant itself.
>> Not to. So, whether I'm hungry?
>> I like that. Here's another one.
What's the weather like. Is it raining outside?
>> Which is a different sense of atmosphere.
>> Right. because if it's raining outside, maybe it's not
your, your favorite choice but you don't want to walk anymore.
Okay, so we have a ton of features here. We've gone
through a few of them. Notice that some of the specifically have
to do with the restaurant and some of them have to do
with things that are external to the restaurant itself but you can
imagine that they're all important. Or possibly important to whether you
should enter into the restaurant or not. Agreed? And there's a bunch
of features you could imagine coming up with that probably have nothing
to do with whether you should enter into the restaurant or not.
Like, how many cars are currently parked across the country.
Probably doesn't have an impact on whether you're going to
enter into a specific restaurant or not. Okay. So, we
have a whole bunch of features and right now we're sticking
with features we think that might be relevant. And we're
going to use those to make some kind of decision. So,
that gets us to decision trees. So, the first thing,
that, that we want to do is, we want to separate
out what a decision tree is from the
algorithm that you might use to build the decision
tree. So the first thing we want to think about is the fact that a decision tree
has a specific representation. Then only after we
understand that representation and go through an example, we'll
start thinking about an algorithm for finding or
building a decision tree. Okay, are you with me?
>> Yeah.
>> Excellent. Okay, so a decision tree is a very simple thing.
Well, you might be, might be surprised to know it's a tree, the first part of
it. And it looks kind of like this. So, what I've drawn for you is example.
Sample generic, decision tree. And what you'll see
is three parts to it. The first thing
you'll see is a circle. These are called
nodes, and these are in fact, decision nodes. So,
what you do here, is you pick a particular attribute. [NOISE]
And you ask a question about it. The answer to that question, which is its
value for what the edges represent in your tree. Okay. So we have these nodes
which represent attributes, and we have edges
which represent value. So let's be specific about
what that means. So here's a particular attribute
we might pick for the top node here.
Let's call it hungry. That's one of the features
that Michael came up with. Am I hungry or
not? And there's only two possible answers for that.
yes, I'm hungry, true, or false, I am not hungry.
And each of these nodes represent some
attribute. And the edges represent the answers
for specific values. So it's as if I'm making a bunch of decisions by asking
a series of questions. Am I hungry? And if the answer is yes, I am
hungry, then I go and I ask a different question. Like is it rainy outside?
And maybe it is rainy and maybe it's not rainy, and let's say if it isn't rainy
then I want to make a decision, and so these square boxes here are the
actual output. Okay so it's hungry, so you're hungry, yes, and it's not
raining, so what do you do? So, let's just say you go in.
True, I go in so, when it's, I'm hungry and it's not raining, I go in.
>> And that, that true is answering a different question. It's not in the
nodes I guess. So, in the leaves, the t and f means something different.
>> That's right. It's the out, that's exactly right. The,
the leaves, the little boxes, the leaves of your decision
tree is your answer. What's on the on the edges
are the possible values that your attribute can take on.
So, in fact, let's try to, let's make that clear by picking a different
by picking another possible attribute. You could
imagine that if I am not hungry, what's
going to matter a lot now is say, the type of restaurant, right. Which we
said there were many, many types of
restaurants. So, you know thai, I forget [CROSSTALK]
>> Italian.
>> Italian, and
you know, something.
>> French fries.
>> And French Fries. So if I'm not hungry, then
what matters a lot more is the type of restaurant,
and so I'll move down this path instead and start
asking other questions. But ultimately, no matter how I, what
this decision tree allows me to do is to ask
a series of questions and depending upon those answers, move
down the tree, until eventually I have some particular ouput
answer, yes I go in the resteraunt, or no I do
not
>> Ok this is still seeming a little abstract to me,
can we, can we maybe work through a very concrete example.
>> Yeah, I think that makes a lot of sense.
>> Let's do a quiz.
>> Ha, okay, let's do a quiz.